retrouvez norvpn la comédie musicale
d'après une histoire vraie d'un logiciel
qui vous propose une protection totale
pour sécuriser votre connexion un compte
aussi envoûant
[Musique]
qu'éprouvant il
bloèes les dangereux éloigne les menaces
et àur sour noi et
[Musique]
vicieuxou arnaque en ligne il st les frs
d'avant
SNE un signal
d'alerte un mur de
défensepn ta Meille présence norvpn la
comédie musicale qui reste active même
quand la connexion VPN ne l' pas et vous
empêche de visiter des sites web produux
qui vous protège des logiciels
malveillants ou des attaques de fishing
avec la voix puissante de spaghetti à
yolli le célèbre chanteur
[Musique]
italienen
laadopter 30 jours pour vous faire
rembourser
assist DISP
jours toujours à votre secours avec le
li
[Musique]
dans music plus de 6h30 de spectacle
interminable offre uniquement valable
par le lien en description
[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 [ __ ] de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Atari ça c'est une marque emblématique
qui a été un tournant dans l'histoire du
jeu vidéo avec Atari on ne s'ennuie plus
devant la télé probablement le premier
grand nom associé aux consoles avec son
modèle le plus iconique à ce jour
l'Atari 2600 une console qui marquera
des millions d'enfants devenus adultes
puis et ça partout à travers le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monde et pourtant comme toutes les
autres consoles de jeux vidéo l'histoire
d'Atari est parsemée d'embûes de
déception de rachat de courbes qui ne
vont pas dans le bon sens de cartouches
enterrées dans le désert de pacman tout
carré d'indien baisé de force par des
militaires contre un cactus de gens qui
se branlent sur un balcon pendant que
quelqu'un et la première galère d'Atari
désormais très connue et très documentée
a lieu lors du premier grand crash du
jeu je vidéo en 1983 transformant Atari
leader mondial du marché en outsider
face à Nintendo qui vient poser ses
grosse couille poilue sous le sapin de
Noël des enfants pour ébranler le marché
bon oui ok d'accord je vais relire mon
script je
reviens pour réagir à la montée de
Nintendo le premier réflexe d'Atari a
été de capitaliser sur leur plus gros
succès la Atari 2600 et la preuve c'est
qu'au milieu des années 80 ils ont sorti
de consoles premièrement la Atari 2600
junior c'est quoi la différence il y a
un autocollant non mais c'est quoi la
différence entre les deux l'autocollant
brille non quelle est la différence
technique entre les deux consoles pardon
je t'écoutais pas j'étais en train
d'admirer ce superbe autocollant et en
1986 laatari 7800 qui était réro
compatible avec les jeux
2600 je par extrm vite pour que les gens
ne se rendent pas compte que tous les
jeux dont je parle c'est de la merde
évidemment ça n'a pas suffi et il a
fallu à la fin des années 80 trouver des
solutions pour rester dans le game Atari
s'est donc associé avec une boîte du nom
de flair technology une société anglaise
constituée d'anciens employés de chez
Saint-Clair qui semblait prête à se
frotter à la féroce compétition des
années 90 avec en tête évidemment la
SuperNes et la Meg driive Atari et flair
décident donc d'utiliser des
technologies issues de leur
micro-ordinateur pour créer en parallèle
les deux consoles qui marqueront le
futur d'Ari à savoir la pantherère et la
Jaguar plus
[Musique]
puissante ah [ __ ] c'était vachement
cool quand même les années
[Musique]
90 quoi qui qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu me
manques quoi mais les années passant le
développement de la Jaguar avançant plus
vite que prévu ils ont donc décidé de
laisser tomber la panthère pour se
concentrer sur la Jaguar Jaguar qui
devint alors la dernière carte à jouer
pour Atari vu qu'il n'avait toujours pas
réussi à rattraper la concurrence dans
le milieu des consoles et que même leurs
ordinateurs commençaient à se faire
distancer par Amiga la Jaguar sort donc
en France en juin 94 soit un peu plus
d'un an avant la Playstation la
Playstation va vous mettre la tête à
l'envers vous remuez les tripes révélez
en vous un sentiment de puissance encore
méconnu des sensations vraies et c'est
la première console 64 bits et ouais 4
bits baby bien avant la Nintendo 64
l'architecture de la console repose sur
deux processeurs 32 bits nommés Tom et
Jerry un processeur pour le son et un
pour la vidéo et tous les deux contrôlés
par un troisième processeur 16 bit qui
était le même qu'on pouvait trouver dans
les megga DRI ce qui du coup si on fait
les maths 32 + 32 64 bits on peut dire
beaucoup de choses on peut dire qu'il
est quatre fois plusiss simpun console
16bit 12 fois plus puissant qu'une
console 32 bits classique à venir 850
fois plus puissant qu'une 16 bit et oui
bravo tu sais faire des multiplications
mais l'informatique ça marche pas comme
ça je Scotte de PS
ensemble ça fait une PS2 et ce côté
faites les matths 64 bits c'est mieux
que 32 c'était tout l'argument marketing
de la console à une époque où personne
ne savait réellement ce que c'était
qu'un bits on avait donc eu droit à tout
un tas de pub agressives he surtout aux
États-Unis pour appuyer là-dessus alors
que pourtant si tu regardes un peu les
images de jeu là qui passent derrière et
tu sens la douille he et et
effectivement la Jaguar s'est révélé
être une bonne grosse console de merde
moi attends quoi quoi j'ai juste dit que
c'était une console de
merde alors non pas du tout c'est juste
qu'on lui a pas laissé le temps de
s'installer enfin c'est mais les jeux
sont dégueulasses c'est parce que
personne y a joué attends regarde on va
commencer par cybermorph c'est un jeu
que tous les possesseurs de Jaguar
avaient tous il était si bien que ça non
mais c'est parce qu'il était fourni dans
la boîte mais en attendant tout le monde
l'avait ah oui ok d'accord c'est le
premier jeu de la console c'est le Mario
64 en fait c'est un peu la démonstration
technique qui doit frapper fort et
rester dans les
mémoires alors moi j'ai juste dit que
c'était le premier effectivement
c'est c'est un peu comme si Bubs 3D
était devenu un jeu de pilotage ah c'est
c'est juste moins agaçant en terme de s
design
[Musique]
non ne fait pas
ça génial c'est la première réaction à
une information dont personne ne mesure
encore les conséquences tu as remarqué
que ça s'est pas effondré bon alors de
ce que je comprends le jeu c'est un truc
à patoun nous il faut ramasser
des des pastilles je sais pas trop ce
que c'est avec d'ailleurs votre vaisseau
qui fait ce bruit très étrange de
déglutition et de temps en temps votre
guide virtuel ou je sais pas trop qui
c'est là apparît pour commenter vos
[Musique]
actions non mais ta gueule ton crâne
rasé là de de de truc W de
merde et le jeu a une suite ça s'appelle
battleemph et c'est pas sorti sur Jaguar
classique c'est sorti sur jaguar cd
c'est une extension CD qui se brancher
par-dessus la Jaguar un petit peu sur le
même modèle que le megga CD pour la
megga drive par contre faut jamais la
quitter des yeux he parce que le
problème c'est que ça ressemble un peu
beaucoup à des chotes oh
merde ah il y a eu combien de jeux sur
ton truc là non ça c'est c'est pas ce
qui est important ce qui est important
c'est 13 jeux 13 jeux même sur cette
merde de 32X il y a eu 40 jeux oui mais
bon là on est sur un support CD on a une
puissance bien plus élevée on va pouvoir
mettre de la musique mais écoute ça mais
ça te défonce AHAR
présente Jaguar attitude la super
compile disponible uniquement chez ton
marchand de
journaux pas mal mais par contre sur la
VO c'était quoi l'idé
[Musique]
exact anglais
écoute si ça te va moi je m'en fous mais
l'avantage du CD c'est aussi la
possibilité de mettre de meilleur
graphisme c'est vra c'est pas le même
jeu
[Musique]
est bleu brefant qu'on est sur jaguar cd
on continue avec Blue Lightning un
afterbner like un classique de la l
satari porté sur jaguar cd et c'est cool
par que regarde on peut voler dans plein
d'endroit du monde comme par exemple la
Russie
du
Sud
l'Europe
l'Australie l'Amérique du Sud allez je
suivant Trevor mcfur in the crissante
galaxie mais qu'est-ce que c'est ce nom
de con là Trevor mcfourure dans la
galaxie du crois ok bon là je suis
d'accord ok ça c'est de la merde hein
c'est pas line de la Jaguar et puis mais
[ __ ] mais regarde ce photomontage
dégueulasse comment ça un montage on a
perdu trois techniciens pour habiller ce
lion effectivement le retour dans la
réalité est assez brutal ah ouais parce
je dis ça pour les gens plus jeunes qui
effectivement s'en rend peut-être pas
compte parce que c'est un vieux jeu mais
ça même pour l'époque c'est de la méga
merde qu'est-ce que c'est que ces
tentatives de trucs expérimentaux là
ok c'est moi qui suis tordu ou vous
voyez une chat en gros plan là non même
si je fais des bruits comme ça avec la
bouche vous allez voir le prochain boss
c'est de la merde
voilà ah c'est une très belle métaphore
de cette console en tout cas il manque
juste les bruitages
mais
[ __ ] désolé je manger un truc pas cool
à midi mais c'est quoi ce bordel
maintenant là le mur d'une maternelle
qu'est-ce que ça fout dans un jeu qui
était dans l'espace il y a 30 secondes
et là c'est c'est c'est quoi ce niveau
là bordel de merde tu fais quoi le jeu
là tu essayes de me tuer ah c'est bon
j'ai mis un truc moins agressif pour les
yeux j'ai nettoyé aussi du
coup club drive on en avait brièvement
parlé de ce jeu il y a longtemps c'est
vrai que le le jeu a l'air de manquer de
budget que ce soit pour l'écran titre
ou ou pour tout le reste à vra
dire on a combien de polygon pour faire
la voiture
de de polygone pour faire la voiture
de de poly
mais deux on a utilisé tous les autres
pour faire le
chat mais attends mais mais c'est pas
comme ça dans mes
souvenirs e maman tu as vu com il est
chouette mon je jaguire le jaguire c'est
la meilleure des consoles vrai maman non
mais je vous dis j'ai tout essayé la
fièvre ne retombe pas j'ai froid maman
où est
l'ambulance Seb ça va oui ben écoutez je
sais pas on peut commencer par parler de
la
musique alors disons que il y a
peut-être un instrument que j'aurais pas
mis et au ballon de
ruche bon alors après le jeu euh bah
disons
que je peux pas allumer ça regardez-le
le pauvre là vous vous voyez bien qu'
qu'il est
différent le chat est une casserole en
3D temps réel
alors bon disons Paron a tendance à
l'oublier mais la Jaguar c'est la
console de RMAN le premier r il est
sorti d'abord sur Jaguar
[Musique]
il c le Do pied il
cas tu le savais ça
tout le et puis je suis désolé tu ne
peux pas mélanger de la mayonnaise et du
ketchup et dire que c'est une sauce
cocktail ça ne marche pas comme ça c'est
pas comme ça qu'on fait de la cuisine
oui
[Musique]
Islander effectivement Highlander sur
jaguar cd un des 13 jeux de la console
et peut-être un des rares vrais jeux un
peu complet du coup puisqu'il s'agit
d'un jeu d'action aventure et
wou le jeu il annonce directement la
couleur avec l'écran titre
on sait qu'on va avoir droit à une
Masterc attends par contre la musique
bug ça a l'air de boucler je vais
redémarrer à con ah non tout va bien là
là c'est normal c'est même la meilleure
musique du jeu
[Musique]
he et ben super donc le jeu est la
deuxème adaptation de Highlander en jeu
vidéo après un jeu dégueulasse sur les
micro ordinateurs de l'époque et
contrairement à ce dernier celui-là est
tiré de la série animée Highlander qui
passait dans les années 90 une merde
parmi tant d'autres que tout le monde a
oublié endeur avec un style graphique
quelconque qui fait penser à toutes ces
chiasses genre James Bond junior et en
voyant l'intro difficile de dire si le
jeu se passe dans le passé ou le futur
ouais en tout cas moi je suis bien dans
le passé là c'est sûr alors le jeu fait
un peu penser à Alone in the Dark he que
ce soit au niveau des placements de
caméra ou des mouvements des personnages
qui sont à base de motion capture ce qui
donne un aspect très réaliste au
mouvement un peu comme dans comme dans
Avatar finalement ah oui je rappelle
quand même que tout l'intérêt de la
jaguar cd normalement c'est le CD qui
permet en théorie de profiter d'une
musique
[Musique]
exceptionnelle tu es sûr que tu veux pas
que je redémarre la console ah mais
t'inquiète pas et puis tiens regarde tu
as trouvé la carte du village car oui
c'est avant tout un jeu d'exploration tu
es sûr que c'est une carte ça on va la
retrouver ton épée quand tu arrives au
pepperoni tu avances vers leolive et tu
Bifur juste ici et puis même au-delà de
son design il y a très très peu
d'informations utile sur cette carte là
ainsi sur cette carte nous pouvons
constater que la porte de devant est à
l'opposé de la porte de derrière et
attends regarde ce coffre dans la maison
là et oui tu as bien vu c'est une
cinématique merci le support CD
ok ouvretoi s'il te plaît donc on se
balade dans le je faire courir moi tu
vas voir le rouquin là-bas on ramasse
des objets qu'on trouve comme ce petit
bâton de bois alors bon ça pas l'air
d'être une arme donc je sais pas ça
servira plus tard je suppose et le
problème évident et absolument
prévisible auquel tout le monde
s'attendait à part visiblement les
développeurs du jeu c'est que les
animations sont beaucoup trop longues et
lentes un souci qu'on avait déjà dans
tous les jeux qui utilisaient ce type de
gameplay y compris dans le l in the dark
et ça fait quoi et ben ça fait ça mais
regardez je dois rentrer dans cette
tente et je ne peux pas parce que dès
que le mec dedans me frappe il me pousse
en arrière et ça me fait
ressortir [ __ ]
de
Chatou les mouvements pue la merde la
balayette vous fait pas tenir en place
c'est impossible à utiliser l'upercute
et le High Kick met 3 ans à sortir en
plus d'avoir une portée de merde quand
tu prends un coup ton perso il a une
animation de recovery c'està-dire
l'animation où tu le voit prendre des
dégâts faire en arrière comme ça là plus
longue que l'animation du garde pour me
[ __ ] un autre coup je me fais casser
la gueule oh mais vas-y c'est bon là je
devrais pas souffrir comme ça dans les 5
premières minutes d'un jeu après bon
vous allez me dire ok je peux toujours
fuir les combats c'est vrai mais pour
aller où péd j'ai pas d'arme et quand
par miracle j'arrive à sortir du village
deux écrans plus loin il y a un tank qui
me tire dessus Ctait bref allez je suis
allé voir une solution et en fait
c'était
évident mais seulement pour un mec
complètement fou en réalité il ne faut
pas passer par cette porte grande
ouverte de devant là comme je
m'acharnais à faire et qui m'emmenait
sur plein de garde non
il faut passer par ce grand portail à
l'arrière et là d'après vous il y a une
immense porte en bois quand je clique
dessus il y a une cinématique qui montre
un Caden fermé trouver une clé pour la
mettre dans le Caden et ouvrir la
serrure bah non on prend le petit bâton
de bois de merde là qu'on a trouvé
plusôt
[Musique]
et alors j'étais en train de réfléchir
et voici une liste de 100 objets plus
pratiques pour ouvrir une
[Applaudissements]
serrure voilà veuillez noter que le
premier est une clé et que la planche de
bois n'arrive qu'en 97e position juste
devant mes couilles bref alors on a le
droit juste après à une petite
cinématique où on en apprend plus sur
l'histoire du jeu en gros dans ce monde
un immortel nommé cortan a pris le
pouvoir du monde tandis que les autres
immortels eux ont lâché l'ffaire du jeu
des immortels et on refusa de se battre
entre eux on les appelle les Gators et
vous voulez savoir pourquoi les Gators
il s'appelle lesator c'est parce qu'ils
ont jeté leur arme à terre ils l'ont
jeté à terre
TER je déconne pas c'est vraiment
l'explication du jeu on est vraiment à
ce niveau
d'écriture oh monu
[Musique]
V jeouss vite immense désert au design
sonore toujours
exceptionnel monsieur bruitage je sais
que vous êtes à la retraite mais on
aurait besoin de dernier
[Musique]
bruitage un désert qui au passage nous
donne quelquesuns des meilleurs combats
du
jeu là on avance dans le jeu on finit
par trouver un pistolet Fisher Price
puis on trouve la manivelle qui permet
de passer un pont aperçu un petit peu
plus tôt dans le jeu
et je vais être honnête on a fait
quelque chose de
mal allez allez
barrez-vous et on s'est jamais vu
ok on a utilisé un code pour
invincible parce que regardez même en
étant invincible je ne peux même pas
passer ce
combat je me fais tellement laver le cul
que je je me peux même pas lever la main
je vois même pas mon perso là comment je
suis censé gagner des combats3 quand je
vois même pas mon personnage [ __ ] et
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que je fous là là à
quoi ils servent ces endroits bqueur en
métal posé au milieu du sable là
salle de contrôle du désert j'écoute
oui je vérifie
oui le désert est toujours
là bref on trouve une barre de fer barre
de fer qu'on utilise pour briser la
serrure du coffre aperçu au début du jeu
toujours aussi fan de la
logique une porte fermée une
clé mais c'est bien
[Musique]
sûr c'est bon la porte est ouverte et
dans le coffre tu vas récupérer une
tenue de garde ah enfin du coup là je
vais l'utiliser pour m'infiltrer et
éviter les combats tant mieux parce que
je t'avoue que les combats c'était
vraiment de la non c'est bizarre comme
idée non tu vas tuer tout le monde sur
le trajet jusqu'à atteindre la zone
suivante des
égouts après tu vas utiliser la tenue de
garde pour ouvrir une porte rentrer
retirer immédiatement la tenue de garde
ah j'aime pas la couleur du coup ils
vont tous te repérer toi normal tu les
chlasses un par un après tu marches
pendant une petite demi-heure jusqu'à
l'ovni tu
fais sur les trucs avec ta main toute
carrée là et ensuite tu trouves une
grosse clé médiévale à utiliser
exclusivement dans l'ordinateur du futur
voilà ça c'est un bon plan ok super
est-ce qu'on peut reparler des égoutts
justement
non mais vraiment c'est un exploit il y
a pas une boucle de son dans ce jeu qui
fasse plus de 2 secondes et c'est quoi
maintenant
là ambiance bruit de pompe de la piscine
et
là on est où là d'un seul coup au spa
vous êtes détendu nous allons procéder
au massage au Capin de raisin ok donc je
reprends où on en était la clé qui
s'appelle clé dans l'ordinateur du futur
et la deuxième clé qui s'appelle pas clé
mais qui est comme la première clé qui
s'appelle clé ouvre la porte du garage
et libère le village des rouquins
oui parce que c'était ça en fait le but
du jeu ok ça y est plus que le boss
final ah vas-y je suis prêt toute façon
on est invincible tu m'envoies le boss
ah non c'est fini c'est la fin tiens
regarde voilà c'est la dernière
[Musique]
cinématique de
fin envie de me [ __ ] en l'air dans ce
jeu il n'y a pas de boss de fin on te
TESE le boss pendant tout le [ __ ] de
jeu avec des scènes du dessin animé mais
la dernière action que tu fais c'est
ouvrir un [ __ ] de
garage attends attends attends 2
secondes mais je réalise mais en fait
mais il y a aucun immortel dans ce jeu
même mon personnage il est pas immortel
vu que j'ai une barre de vie à la base
tu demandes à n'importe qui de te
décrire Highlander il va te dire bah
c'est des immortels qui affronent
d'autres immortels avec une épée et à la
fin il y en a un qui gagne il décapit
plot il y a des éclairs il doit en
rester qu'un mais mais là il y a rien de
tout ça non mais ok d'accord tout n'est
pas parfait mais regarde cette scène
cinématique de fin là on voit clairement
que Final Fantasy 7 a tout
pompé cette scène avec la passerelle
c'est pareil
Islander c'est le prototype de Final
Fantasy
7 quoi mais regarde-moi ces
graphismes c'est magnifique cette
finesse incomparable cette texture C
lice ce RTX ce DSS je fre l'isotropique
x 16 ok je pense que tu devrais
peut-être prendre une pause et je vais
faire ma conclusion pendant ce temp là
la Jaguar marquera donc la fin
officielle d'Atari en tant que fabricant
de console avec ses mauvaises
performances l'absence de jeux japonais
et sa difficulté de programmation parce
que vous vous demandez peut-être
pourquoi avec 64 bits les jeux
ressemblaient à
ça c'est parce que le développement sur
Jaguar et sur les deux processeurs 32
bits était tellement complexe que en
général les développeurs préférés
développer sur le troisième processeur
celui qui était censé seulement diriger
les deux autres mais qui avait la
puissance d'un processeur de méga drive
mais à postériori c'est aussi clairement
le marketing qui l'a ridiculisé Jaguar
Jaguar Jaguar Atari virera une grosse
partie de ses employés en 1995
fusionnera avec JTS un fabricant de
disque dur et sera finalement racheté
par Hasbro en 1998 la marque Atari
restera dans les poches de HASBRO
pendant quelques années à prend la
poussière avant d'être racheté en 2001
par
infogramme et oui unari existe toujours
enfin plutôt infogramme existe toujours
et s'appelle dorénavant Atari donc pour
revenir à ce que je disais plutôt oui la
Jaguar et ben c'est de la merde parce
que non seulement la console elle est
franchement pas ouf il y a eu une tonne
de jeux complètement pourriis dessus
mais en plus elle a signé la fin d'une
des marques les plus importantes de
l'histoire du jeu vidéo donc bah pour
moi Seb tu délires complètement je veux
dire on peut pas sérieusement aimer la
Jaguar on est en 94 il y a plein de gens
qui se sont fait arnaquer en achetant
cette merde alors qu'ils auraient pu
acheter la Playstation non vraiment
aimer la Jaguar c'est se mentir à
soi-même c'est quoi cette tête mais tu
vas vraiment défendre la Jaguar tu
prétends que Trevor mcfur c'est un bon
jeu peut-être oui je l'ai dit et j'en ai
marre de faire comme si ça nétait pas
c'est subjectif les gofred c'est les
gens qu' me fout d'ailleurs le problème
vous décrétez quelle console est bien ou
pas quel jeu bon ou mauvais mais tout ça
c'est juste une vaste blague hein une
vaste blague et ça te fait rire il y a
des gens qui ont acheté une Jaguar il
faut acheter un périphérique pour jouer
à seulement 13 jeux et ça te fait rire
les jeux Jaguar valent encore une
fortune sur ebay et ça te fait rire tout
ça c'est une blague pour toi oui je sais
tu veux une autre blague Fred non non
non non je pense qu'on a entendu assez
de Black qu'est-ce que tu obtiens si tu
mélanges deux processeurs 32 bits qui
s'appelle Tom Jer
po s'il vous plaît quelqu'un peut
appeler la police les [ __ ] de Mad
[Musique]
[Rires]
Fred bonne année
ouais attends tu es sûr que la vidéo
sortirait début janvier ben attends
c'est pas notre genre de louper les
délis hein et bonne année 2025 bonne
année
c'est
parti ou
ouais on continue par a plus de crédit
c'est les crédit pu personne regarde
[Rires]